the way money is spent in this country
is really obscene there was a breakdown
of weapons in the paper about a week ago
in an effort so that the ordinary person
in the street could understand what's
going on the stealth fighter is it the
the f-18 the f-18 a sitting there on the
runway costs a hundred and ten million
dollars you know what you can buy if you
have a hundred and ten million dollars
on the civilian market you can buy the
Trump princess that's what the Trump
princess cost olicity about your
acquisition of the boat this summer
the princess is that when I caught a
boat from Adnan Khashoggi which was
formerly called the Nabila
Nabila it's a yacht and Adnan Khashoggi
excuse me for a second is the world's
largest arms trader I hate to admit it
well now we think of Trump as just the
exemplar of obscene wealth I mean this
guy what a pig all this money all of his
money buys him one f18 a we build these
things by the dozens dream of selling
them by the hundreds so you know as
Donald Trump a pig what about their
levels and levels some people make an
easy target the amount of money being
spent on armament as opposed to the
amount of money being spent on anything
else
the cure of disease housing education
you name it is totally schizophrenic Lee
skewed I keep the engines off as much as
possible but it's as substantial as a
swimming pool on it it's got a swimming
pool and a pizza oven it's got just
about everything into it
can you could you could he makes me feel
very guilty about this hugs I like to do
other good things I have to end it no
you shouldn't feel guilty about this
because I mean you've worked hard for
this money or reasonably hard I mean I
don't see you doing a lot of heavy
lifting but you know